vivre une parenthèse sauvage au coeur de
la forêt amazonienne dans les pas des
premiers amérindiens
pour certains cela ressemble à l'enfer
vert pour d'autres un rêve de gosse
[Musique]
michel à loïc est un amérindiens wayana
il a été le premier à proposer aux
touristes une expédition au coeur de son
territoire
l'une des expéditions les plus
exigeantes de guyane un périple qui
remonte le fleuve maroni jusqu'à sa
source jusqu'au mont tumu cumac à la
frontière du brésil des sommets c'est
difficile à atteindre qu'ils sont
devenues mythiques
l' aventure démarre au coeur de la plus
grande forêt du monde à une heure
d'avion de cayenne au sud ouest de la
guyane à maripasoula sur les rives du
fleuve maroni face au surinam
maripasoula c'est une ville créée de
toutes pièces au milieu du xxème siècle
après la découverte de l'or dans la
région
[Applaudissements]
maripasoula c'est aussi la porte
d'entrée du territoire amérindien le
lieu où michel à loïc et prépare ses
voyages vers les tumeurs cumac dans 24
heures il recevra six nouveaux clients
prêts à se confronter à la magie et à la
brutalité de la masoni les trois quarts
du périple se feront en pirogue la
pirogue traditionnelle des amérindiens
il ya déjà le bois principal qui est
taillée dans un tronc il est coloré noir
parce que tout simplement il a été brûlé
pour pouvoir les cartes et et c'est un
vrai et c'est un vraie arme le plus
souvent l'arbre qu'on utilise pour faire
le bois celle angélique est alors gély
que la particularité de cette de ce bois
là c'est que les fibres sont mêlés donc
si un choc il se casse pas facilement
voilà et puis car le dossier avec teaser
huit heures de navigation
on a besoin d'un petit dossier comme ça
pour avoir le confort
voilà
relatif ben oui il faut que ça fasse un
peu l'aventuré c'est ça la magie ils
touchent la pirogue comme ça je peux
fixé le moteur qui abritera la bonne
dame
l'expédition durera dix jours remontera
le fleuve maroni jusqu'à la frontière du
brésil près de 200 km vers le sud de la
guyane de maripasoula hautmont tumu
cumac au coeur du parc amazonien
normalement interdite d'accès le jour du
départ les candidats à l'aventuré ont
rendez vous à l'embarcadère de maripa
soula
ils sont six six copains qui viennent
d'arriver de cayenne et rêve de se
confronter aux plus rude de la guyane il
y à seb agents edf et rugbyman
julien ingénieur et chasseurs mais dix
kinésithérapeutes et boxeur mais aussi
benoît laurent janvier
[Musique]
bah j'espère que vous êtes des bons
pêcheurs en effet essayé
[Musique]
en prenait dû voir la vie
nominé robin et on s'est limité
mais là bas qu'on protège de bagages et
mille autres par dessus ils partiront
avec deux pirogues et quatre
accompagnateurs amérindiens mais là on
va donner les papiers n'ont pas leur
problème
dernière formalité avant de partir une
visite à la gendarmerie de maripasoula
aux gens c'est un passage obligé pour ce
genre d'expédition
seule une autorisation préfectorale
exceptionnelle peut donner accès à cette
zone protégée du territoire amérindien
au début c'était surtout une mesure
sanitaire ça l'est toujours
en fait c'est pour éviter d'aller allait
redonner des maladies ou aux autochtones
quoi pour éviter trop de revient lancer
dans ces régions là c'est fait pour
protéger les gens en fait et puis tant
pour cent au cas où les gens ne
reviendrait pas aux dates prévues ça
nous permet éventuellement de lancer des
recherches ou des choses comme ça
d'accord donc on cherche ce qu'on
cherche
peu l'aventuré allait dans les endroits
où toute personne arrêtée marrant doute
qu'en sais pas pourquoi pas les mesures
auront une coupure avec la civilisation
les voitures les téléphones plus de
réseau c'est mon secteur
vous devez rentrer donc normalement le
28 mené le match messieurs bons rails
allait dévoiler combien c'est ça ouais
la branche comme en baroeul
michel à loïc et va leur ouvrir les
portes de ce territoire méconnu le
territoire de ses ancêtres
[Musique]
peuple de la forêt les amérindiens sont
les premiers habitants de la guyane au
xvème siècle ils sont plus de trente
mille
[Musique]
décimés par la colonisation les
épidémies et la destruction de leur
environnement ils ne sont plus que six
mille aujourd'hui dont seulement 800
wayana
[Musique]
quelques jours avant le départ vers les
tumultes mac nous avions accompagné
michel dans son village
un tacle à nez sur les bords du fleuve
maroni
il est le petit neveu du grand chef des
wayana à my poti
moi quand j'étais jeune j'étais guide
aussi et porte
j'emmenais des blancs forêt avec la
pirogue des explorateurs qui allait vers
les tumultes du bac les bagages des
blancs étaient très lourds et quand il y
avait des arbres en travers de la
rivière
c'était difficile on lui ait coupé avec
la hache
on n'avait pas de tronçonneuses dès
l'âge de 18 ans michel a accompagné ses
expéditions
à l'époque elle était réservée aux
explorateurs ou aux scientifiques pour
ouvrir ce territoire au tourisme il lui
a fallu l'autorisation de son
grand-oncle et de la communauté wayana
ton projet d'emmener des touristes c'est
bien je les accepte et parce que
l'avenir ici c'est difficile
là ça te donne du travail sinon vous
feriez quoi vous les jeunes wayana
c'est une blague
élevée par son grand père michel a
choisi de rester au pays être need
c'est l'opportunité de faire connaître
une culture la sienne aujourd'hui menacé
je montre à tout le monde la façon de
comment nous on vit il faut qu'ils
sachent que on a aussi pas par la vie
occidental nous aussi on a la vie
culturelle quoi une vraie cité touristes
ne sont pas corrects il faut les amener
faut bien réfléchir s'ils sont bien il
respecte nos traditions tu seras bien
aussi et il nous comprendre il y aura
pas de problème
à chaque expédition michel initie ses
clients dès le premier jour aux
traditions amérindiennes
à commencer par l'incontournable
caschili la bière locale
amusez-vous goûter ils vont aimer et ça
leur ouvre à investir
dans le village michel a grandi c'est sa
mère qui la préparent le cash iris et
une boisson à 5 degrés d'alcool
fabriqués à base de manioc fermenté et
pour affronter les tumeurs cumac michel
en a prévu 20 litres elle est prête mais
oui qu'on tirait benoît et sébastien
vont être les premiers à tester
[Musique]
alors c'est bon ça passe très bien je
sais pas quel effet ça fait si on en
boit des litres ça passe très bien
[Musique]
michel par trois fois par an loin des
siens pour cette expédition au parfum
d'aventuré aujourd'hui à l'ema sa petite
fille de 8 ans ferait bien partie du
voyage
[Musique]
parti avec moi mais je coupe à la mener
c'est pas dangereux c'est difficile quoi
c'est tout
on pressent qu'on marche dans la boue
sien il ya des serpents et des anacondas
des jaguars l'année prochaine je t'amène
à quoi bon ben on va aller à l'ema
allait vraiment mon mandat
ces raids
[Musique]
l'expédition redémarre avec un peu de
retard il faut maintenant rejoindre pis
dima le dernier village amérindien du
parcours il est prévu d'y dormir ce soir
avant de quitter la civilisation pour
s'enfoncer dans la forêt vierge
les six membres de l'expédition
connaissent tous la nature guyanaise
les sorties en forêt mais aucun d'eux ne
s'est jamais aventuré aussi loin
rejoindre les cumuls max est un défi
tout particulier pour jean vic 56 ans
mécanicien dans l'armée le doyen du
groupe
bah je suis pas très très très jeune et
comme mes amies sont beaucoup plus
jeunes que moi donc il y avait un truc
physique mais si j'ai fait pas mal
d'expédition deux parents travaillent
déjà et je sais ce que c'est mais sur
dix jours c'était pas mal que cela
[Musique]
l'appréhension de dire je vais pas y
arriver je vais peut-être me faire mal
je vais peut-être souffrir mais une part
iv la route et puis relâché content je
l'étais voilà j'y suis arrivé est arrivé
avant cela il va falloir affronter les
caprices du maroni et franchir c'est
rapide
nous sommes en saison sèche l'eau et
basse les rochers à fleur
je crois que ça passe le rapide par la
forêt dater
à l'avant de la pirogue pour aider
michel il y a le jeune k cariste à la
gouaille le tas car et c'est mon
deuxième run il est là pour montrer
l'endroit où il ya le rocher donc il a
un petit tas carré pour pouvoir voir la
profondeur de l'eau et c'est en fonction
de ça que moi je peux décéléré ou bien
accéléré et c'est un travail avec une
précision
si tu rates par exemple 2 centimes elle
dans un rapide du risque de chavirer
très vite la situation se complique les
rochers sont de plus en plus nombreux et
la nuit ne va pas tarder à tomber
il va falloir s'arrêter plus tôt que
prévu
ce sera au village amérindien de técou
matin 300 habitants un petit coin de
france au bout du monde où les coutumes
reste wayana lorsqu'on s'arrête il faut
toujours demander leur autorisation le
chef du village ne pas débarquer comme
ça parce que faut savoir que
le villageois ont leur propre vie
en on essaie on essaie au maximum 2
n'est pas les déranger a hanté coumba
tall le chef du village est un lyonnais
installé ici depuis plus de 50 ans le
seul chef blanc d'un village amérindien
bonjour tu vas bien ouais
si tu veux j'ai une maison qui est vide
la nuit arrivée j'ai touché plus rocher
avec le moteur ok installe toi mais
c'est ça c'est ça qui pimentent
laventure à la bonne franquette comment
ce n'est qu'il y aura une petite corde
aventures de deux joueuses n'ont prévu
et d'un corps isation c'est pas dès le
premier jour mais bon donneur
[Applaudissements]
quasiment dialoguer via le toit comment
vous êtes organisé la monarchie qui est
désordonnée c'est à dire qu'il y en a
qui seront remises sur c'est de ce côté
avec pas mal de pente
du coup ils vont dormir un peu assis et
puis du coup diagonale ici là voilà on
en met on en est où on peut on n'aime
pas mais moi j'adore j'adore aussi mieux
voire mieux qu'elle y soit pour faire la
sieste pour la nuit
[Applaudissements]
à 5h30 michel et le premier debout
c'est le petit déjeuner à chérie c'est
l'horizon
il a dormi avec les autres piroguiers à
proximité du fleuve pour garder un oeil
sur les embarcations comme on a beaucoup
de chargement la du matériel on
surveille quand même on ne sait jamais
si on a des manques de sens où c'est pas
bon pour l'âme et c'est après partir des
voleurs donc par exemple du carburant
c'est très recherché comme ça un saut
veille
regardons j'étais connaît on allume la
lumière s'accorder
dans le groupe de copains c'est benoît
le plus matinal chargé d'affaires dans
le btp il vit depuis quatre ans en
guyane mais en moins de 24 heures il
s'est offert un dépaysement total
se réveiller en technipat à un petit
village amérindien comme ça en plein sur
le fleuve c'est toujours un petit côté
de nos côtés aventure mais petit côté
magique
avant que avec des amérindiens c1 une
fois personnellement j'ai jamais mis un
pied
qu'est ce que c'est
inattendu c'est pas sûr qu'on va foncer
c'est magique pour vous dire que
l'attitude
[Musique]
na qui ont plus de mal à se lever
j'ai besoin de repos mais c'est ce que
je leur explique mais veut pas
comprendre
moi je suis un thé mais dit tu étais un
petit et pas de grasse matinée au
programme
au deuxième jour de l'expédition il va
falloir passer les rapides les plus
sérieux du maroni
très vite ils deviennent infranchissable
papier
voilà messieurs maintenant il ya une
grande forme je vous propose d'aller
devons tirer est longue et de la pirogue
ok on va pousser un peu par là
dès le matin
là
quémande au complet saison des pluies du
coup il faut de quoi tu veux tirer
pousser ma part fois délesté mais les
chars plus loin mais pas dire
c'est physique mais bon on est dans
l'autre sens
[Applaudissements]
cette première période voilà on fait don
de deux pages de france
bon ok froid
[Applaudissements]
center parcs ses livres
reste comme des petits fous
on voit la caséine maman bon ok ok ok ok
c'est dur là c'est dur parce que souvent
la caisse
à l'arrivée on va y arriver qu'est ce
qui te plaît
sache que tu as fait ça qu'ici
si tu fais rien comprendre tena soit ici
là tu restes là tu étais inquiétudes au
plus au hockey
là on est tous ensemble
voilà
ça vous fait rire de voir passer des
vacances
ça dépend connais tu es la ville a vite
déchanté quand on n'était pas passé
comme ça tous les jours
g au t
juste là où l'intérêt de fuir
pour passer moins de 200 m 2 rapide il
aura fallu plus de deux heures d'efforts
acharnés
certains se seraient découragés et en
redemande et ça tombe bien des rapides
il y en aura d'autres à franchir ce
matin là
le plaisir c'est participer de vivre
l'expérience vive l'expédition
quand on tire une pirogue dans un
endroit dangereux comme dans le seau
quand on est en galère en 2h sur des
petits passages ya une grosse cohésion
on va tous apprendre ce produit en force
encourageant mental et on est fatigué
comme tout le monde tout le monde met la
main à la pâte
le résultat il dépend de nous il dépend
pas que des guides évoqué la pause
déjeuner cette api dima sous la
protection du vieux chef qui a donné son
nom au village
monsieur py dit ma venue
si vèdoko une sorte de coque sauvage
chasser le matin même la tête
en accompagnement le couac la semoule de
manioc séché environnement
ça c'est la base des sens art en haleine
tous les jours bon ben bon appétit c'est
bon j'ai gagné qui dit mas sera le tout
dernier village traversé avant de
plonger pour de bon dans la forêt vierge
bon allez
on va y aller merci monsieur climat il
reste 150 kilomètres à parcourir avant
de rejoindre les tumeurs cumac en plein
coeur du territoire interdit
loin de toute zone habitée un fantasme
pour des générations d'explorateurs
[Musique]
au 19ème siècle jules crevon chirurgien
dans la marine et le premier européen
dans l aventure
il veut cartographier cette chaîne de
montagne censé marquer la frontière avec
le brésil
il sera selon la légende dévoré par une
tribu d'indiens anthropophage
en 1949
raymond m'offrait journaliste aventurier
de 23 ans décide à son tour
d'entreprendre ce périple en solitaire
ans
un chasseur amérindiens retrouvera ses
carnets de voyage sur le bord du fleuve
mais on ne reverra jamais le jeune
explorateur
com
c'est quand même un mythe c'était un peu
une sorte d'eldorado don de pouvoir
guérir
alors que beaucoup d'explorateurs s'y
sont cassé les dents c'est cela qui est
le vrai défi ce lieu mythique
franchement de l'amazonie je pourrais
dire j'y suis allé
pour atteindre les tumu cumac ils se
sont préparés à l'aventuré mais sans
forcément imaginer tous les cas de
figure qu'est-ce qui se passe bah en
panne et un problème de chez pathé
chaque mois ou le boucher ou les
batteries paris souvent on y croit
toujours mais des fois oui moi tu
retournes and they come back à prendre
les sens oui j'en ferai une bâche aussi
oui et je prends un nouveau moteur il va
falloir attendre le retour du 2e
piroguiers pour le moment l'expédition
est au point mort faut savoir que y'a
pas le magasin à côté lorsque tu es à
kayes m tu as un souci et du moteur de
voiture
tu sais que le garagiste il est à 200
mètres de toi ici
on se calme on se pose on sait qu'on va
y arriver et
et
et surtout ne pas s'énerver parce que
quelques si tu t'énerves que tu
t'énerves où tu t'énerves est pas le
problème restera donc on attend et on va
partir
[Musique]
les rations le temps passe les minutes
puis les heures les cumuls mac n'ont
jamais semblé aussi loin c'est un peu
dommage ça commençait à être par nature
pas seulement maintenant c'est sûr que
si on n'arrive pas à monter ce sera
compliqué mauvaise nouvelle
michel leur apprend que le piroguier ne
reviendra pas sans donner d'explications
il va falloir faire demi-tour repartir
au village précédent pour y dormir et
croiser les doigts pour que la nuit
apporte une solution
on va y arriver
[Musique]
le lendemain matin il y à bien deux
pirogues prêt à partir comme souvent
chez les wayana la solution est trouvée
en famille c'est yann l'oncle de michel
qui nous accompagnera finalement authume
cumac cette phase est
[Applaudissements]
vous
pour rattraper le temps perdu l'objectif
aujourd'hui c'est minimum huit heures de
navigation en milieu de matinée
il fait déjà près de 40 degrés
tous un petit peu ces longues périodes
sur la pirogue
on n'a pas de protection en plein
cagnard
couvert un peu les cuisses dormir un mac
avec des gros coups de soleil sur des
jambes
le faire une fois pour savoir que
que c'est beau à voir
[Musique]
en s'enfonçant vers le sud le lit de la
rivière se rétrécir moins de 30 mètres
séparent désormais deux berges et deux
pays
[Musique]
pour des basses et le surinam
voilà c'est la guyane france
et il faut encore que les wayne n'avait
pas de frontières et ce sont les autres
lenteurs sont venus mettre les lignes et
là
là c'est la forêt de côté c'est la forêt
c'est chez moi
[Musique]
mais j'ai pas de faute y a pas de
frontières pour
o o
le coeur du territoire wayana le
territoire interdit
c'est une forêt inextricable la nature à
l'état brut
les hommes sont rares à parvenir
jusqu'ici ils me sont que tolérée c'est
une ambiance particulière qu'on ressent
pas vraiment ailleurs il ya le fait
d'être même si on est sur le fleuve le
fait d'être entouré par les arbres et
par là par la nature ça fait vraiment
l'impression d'être un peu pris dedans
pris dans le bon sens du terme pas
piéger mais
on sent que plus ça avance et
et plus on en fait partie avec 7
finalement trois quatre jours on
marie va atteindre des zones qui sont
quasiment vierge
soit 2 km en plein jour et c'est assez
rare de voir ses larmes
10e quoi et ça c'est vraiment unis
dans ce secteur la chasse est
strictement interdite
sauf pour les amérindiens qui ne tuent
qu'en cas de strictes nécessités et ce
soir il va bien falloir manger un iguane
en apéritif ici cela devient presque
normal mais pour 10 c'est un peu juste
[Musique]
également qu'allemands cayman
non non tu n'as pas l'oeil de la
méfiance totale
l'apprenant
il pousse c'est bon tu peux y aller
qui tu vas en enfer je suis là
on va faire ce soir avec ça
mais bon oui c'est long
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
avec près de 10 heures de navigation
aujourd'hui une bonne partie du retard a
été rattrapé la frontière sud de la
guyane et le secteur des tumeurs cumac
ne sont plus qu'à une journée de pirogue
en attendant il va falloir improviser un
campement pour passer la nuit
essaye de dégager ici là ça a l'air pas
mal ça va frapper c'est bien là
il vous plaît ce camping et c'est pas un
quatre étoiles mais bon c'est ce qu'on
est venu chercher ta première fois
vraiment en pleine forêt où il faut tout
déblayé en écrasant de plus ça paraît
pas très hospitaliers à première vue là
non
avec d'autres un peu de confort si
berlin et quand ils étaient encore en
place mais un club de vacances où il est
quand même conseillé de tout accroché en
hauteur pour éviter les mauvaises
rencontres
l'élu charpente attention je vais
pouvoir prendre son parcours assez
dangereux et des petites bêtes les
petites bêtes
les araignées après bon aux animaux plus
en plus les gens si longtemps peur de
nous que nous les longues et chaudes on
veut bien cramé les ailes à la douche
non après quand on verra plus les
bestioles l'on croyait quelques années
j'ai quand même des gros iranien a vu le
groupe iranien qui va sortir
elles mêmes a roulé noir mais cela ils
sont beaux et ça fait longtemps que
j'avais pas vu des gros comme ça
[Musique]
pendant ce temps en cuisine
la brigade wayana s'activent crochet
pour les cayman et boyaux petit boyau un
pop fait une brochette pour moi j'ai un
petit peu pas beaucoup mahb par
pique-niqué quoi c'est unis qui vont
jamais retrouvés dans un restaurant
ailleurs qu'au la même pas dans un bon
restaurant de luxe du champs elysées km
en bronze tout comme un peu pour
l'épreuve genre il faut dire que c'est à
dire plusieurs l'avion nous entre
sondage papa même que je reprends
n'avait pas mis que trois questions
demeurent
[Musique]
sans un guide amérindiens aucun d'eux
n'aurait pu parvenir jusqu'ici cette
expédition c'est l'opportunité
incroyable de découvrir la plus ancienne
civilisation de guyane
je pense qu'on pourra dire on connaît un
petit peu plus la culture wayana ils ont
une facilité à s'adapter ou au lieu à la
nature à utiliser n'importe quelle
branche chaude pour faire un pieu une
ramsay on se rend compte au final que
ils ont 22 pas grand chose
[Musique]
sur les animaux tout ça les wayana et
vont quand même beaucoup de choses à
nous apprendre
là dessus c'est ton goût et du singe à
saint girons saint leu de ce côté-là ça
c'est assez impressionnant
tout est naturel tout la naturel pour
eux on voit qu'ils ont vécu dans ce
milieu là depuis
plus ça va plus on a envie aussi de
découvrir de découvrir la culture de
découvrir leur manière de cuisiner des
techniques de pêche duchesse choses qui
peuvent nous apporter qu'on verra nulle
part ailleurs
[Musique]
le dernier jour de navigation avant de
rejoindre le pied des tum cumac
s'annonce plus rude encore que les
autres il faut dégager la rivière bloqué
par d'énormes troncs faut essayer de
couper le gros tout de suite on pourra
mettre l'autre en travers
pas question de se blesser à ce stade
nous sommes à plus de 100 km du premier
dispensaire son réseau téléphonique
coupée du monde
on y voit les cols du grand yves gallégo
n'est pas allé les petits troncs de
grand-mère qui vont nous arrêter là
le niveau de l'eau en cette fin de
saison sèche est au plus bas l'érosion
sur les berges provoque la chute de
centaines d'arbres
dans ce secteur où personne ne
s'aventure habituellement la nature
reprend ses droits
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors là je la vend plus on n'est pas
rendu y a des jours tu passais pas ce
qui lui est arrivé
allez les français on paye jamais les
bras jamais
[Musique]
six heures et une vingtaine d'autres ont
plus tard l'amazonie devenue l'école de
la patience a fait louper
j'ai passé rapide aussi j'adapte une
branche tu vois pas pk pourquoi iguanes
et d'épaisseur manger et a dit qu'il
avait des tuques
on est parfois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il aura fallu 9 heures pour parcourir
les 20 derniers kilomètres et arrivait
enfin au pied du talent wac m l'un des
points culminants des tumeurs cumac le
talent wac m
un sommet de granit dressé en pleine
forêt amazonienne 720 mètres qu'il
faudra gravir demain ce sera sans doute
l'étape la plus difficile pour des
charges pour toutes au touquet
[Musique]
après
[Applaudissements]
bon vent monsieur sac à dos à dos que
au départ il ya la forêt moi tu danses
[Musique]
tapie
je crois
et
vous
[Musique]
faut savoir que là c'est rien du tout
tout à l'heure on va arriver sur le
passage où il ya la boue n'essayez pas
d'éviter la boue parce que fos qui
rêvent de vous faire mal dans le coeur
[Musique]
après la bourre vient la montée raide
très raide radio
[Musique]
j'ai eu un petit proverbe qui dit petit
petit petit petit qu'à monter montagne
petit petit à petit la tortue montrent
la montagne je crois plus ou moins peu
importe le temps qu on m a souffert on y
arrivera
[Musique]
là on va attaquer la partie rockeur va
pas il ya un petit coin pour hendaye but
est de nous au bout de trois heures
d'une ascension éprouvante
il faut franchir les roches sacré elle
servait d'abri aux wayana pendant la
colonisation et autres quand on lui
parle on cherchait désandrouins toujours
très difficile à l'accès du pouvoir ceux
des fonds pour les colons qui de venir
ici pour chercher des amis et mon sport
qu'on a reculé reculé pour que ce soit
plus protégé par la nation
bon les gars
il est 14 heures quand le groupe sort de
la forêt il fait plus de 40 degrés et le
périple n'est pas à son terme
[Applaudissements]
magnifique
ça vaut le coup on est au début j'étais
le wacken et du coup encore marcher un
petit peu pour se mettre à l'ombre
voilà on en plein soleil donc on va
marcher une bonne heure en plein soleil
j'espère que j'aurai fait qu'on a connu
là
[Musique]
au sommet la récompense c'est une vue à
couper le souffle sur trois pays guyane
surinam brésil 720 mètres au dessus de
la canopée
je suis toujours ému lorsque je viens
ici et je suis tant que je serai encore
debout je pense que je ferai toujours ce
métier et aussi partager avec d'autres
personnes qui viennent de loin et cck
pas le moyen là on est venu comme ça et
on a suivi les crêtes des crêtes les
crêtes les crêtes des crêtes décrite
jusqu'à revenir comme ça tu en as fait
toc toc toc toc
karl est à la pointe simon se soit ancré
peut-être petit lyonnais pour s'en
remettre à sa place au niveau de la
planète quoi on fait partie d'un élément
on est voilà c'est pas nous les maîtres
ont cerné par les patrons avaient pas
les bois pendant deux jours et deux
nuits la vie va s'organiser au sommet du
tableau hakem une vie de robinson sur le
toit de l'amazonie le luxe des derniers
instants loin de la civilisation moderne
il ya vraiment la notion de quitter le
confort d'avoir pas grand chose mais au
final on se rend compte de ce qu'on a de
ce qui est vraiment essentiel que c'est
important ça fait du bien j'ai rarement
ressenti ces sensations là c'est très
rare
une petite appréhension au fait de
rentrer et on sera très content de
retrouver la petite femme mais après le
portable la voiture tombée sur dix jours
on est franchement ennuyeux sans quoi je
pense que tu rentreras un peu
différentes expéditions différent je
t'ai pas oui certainement en tout cas
plus peut-être je vais rentrer chez moi
je serai peut-être plus a&p des plus
plus tranquille
ce sera oui peut-être un peu différent
ici soit
[Musique]
m
e
il est
oui
grâce à michel le guide amérindiens ils
seront une trentaine chaque année à
pouvoir se réveiller un peu différent au
sommet des cumuls mac
l'eldorado de ceux qui rêvent dans notre
tourisme loin de sa zone de confort sur
les pas des premiers habitants de guyane
sur les traces d'un mythe
et
[Musique]
fondée en minute si l'om est bon